beautifully wrapping a present is a way
of making your last minute [ __ ] gift
seem fantastic I grew up with my dad on
your toy store just a fat guy in a
little coat he doesn't like it
boohoo let's do this usually if you're
good enough for a wrapper you don't
actually have to cut you can just kind
of slide and you get the half crack
right here edges right
you're just a rated scissor so it's a
little bit tougher Oh beautifully we
ramped to present for getting your kid a
ball like why are you wrapping it this
one's a little tougher this is so hard
it's getting there it's getting there
with the ball every side is up back in
the glory days I wrapped a four foot
giraffe with my dad you know what this
is the best it's gonna get on this side
it's like them and most people get
freaked out by these but they're
actually not that bad doesn't need
wrapping it's like an operating table
we're gonna tuck your head between your
legs I'm gonna get a little kinky with
the bear my mom taught me how to just
like slide the oh little Christmas
burrito might as well just put this in a
garbage bag and be like hey I got you
some crap what kid wants a globe don't
he's gonna box
there's no South Sudan oh we're gonna
make a little globe burrito I'd rather
get cold than a globe you know what as
I'm doing this I'm beginning to really
feel like gift cards like a great idea